Listen to listen no you listen to me
actually do you support listen I won
this not your country your country I'm
not listening to you you listen you're
not going to do nothing about it listen
to me I don't want to read okay you have
read it yes have you read it yourself
have you you're being rud shut up you
know that guy Iranian guy told you he
would cut your ear off you remember that
guy my face man do you know who is you
want me to tell you who he is move out
my face move my face he get to my face
my face Mo my face my face my friend my
friend my friend the government the
government Manchester AR
Bridge second if you invaded Iraq and
killed 1 million people move your camera
out my face move out my face move out my
face I'll will take your mask off I will
take your mask off now I will take your
mask off I would trust me I will take
your mask off I will take your mask off
aggressive be careful I will you very
you H me you H me I will you
cont you're being
aggressive Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be AAR for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you
can most pedopiles most most most
pedophiles most pedophiles are white and
midle Men no no they look like the
majority in the UK are all [__]
muslim Muslims actually check one second
say wait one second one second Che one
second one second most pets are white
middle-aged men oh is it yes how do you
know ask how Okay one second problem the
majority of the pet Rings one of the
biggest cases that happened by the nbcc
was in Scotland by by four four
Caucasians we say four Caucasians three
of the men one of them Woman They
stuffed one of the children in the
microwave that gave them cocaine drugs
and sexually abused them this was one of
the worst cases in nbcc records that me
finished in Scotland done by Caucasians
but you don't care you know why because
to you if it's a white man doing it it's
fine it's okay so condemn it you about
pedopilia you talk about you come over
illegally I have you're watching too
much Tommy Robinson tell every Tommy no
I'm I'm I'm a fan of Tommy Robson of
course you are you donate him and it's
not cocain and goes to prostitutes I'm a
ex I can see you are now let's have look
have a fan of listen I'm a fan fan of
Islam yeah do you sport Hamas
alhamdulillah I I I like do you sport
sorry it's fine it's fine it's fine
listen to me brother listen no no answer
my question do you support Hamas can you
shut up and let me no no no so you're
being rude to me do you support Israel
do you support Israel I I don't I don't
support anyone support Israel do you
support Israel I'm not saying I support
to Israel okay I'm asking a question
Tommy Robinson supports Israel do you
support Israel I I I don't Israel is a
country yes that's
do you support the IDE isra is a country
I I I support my own country good good
good okay your country ask the same
question do do you support one second
I'm asking
question Len to listen no no you listen
to me
actually do you support listen listen
listen to me your country this your
country I'm not listening to you you
listen to you're not going to do nothing
about it listen to me I never said I was
this your country this my country no do
you support listen to me listen to me
listen to me do why you asking me a
question that's irrelevant to the
equation I'm talking about Islam I'm not
talking about an
organization my friend it's an
irrelevant discussion it's discussion
it's an irrelevant discussion clearly
proven to me I'm asking a
question you said you said Islam is not
Islam religion of Peace relig where did
you get that from where did I get that
from I kind of agree with it like it's
not totally just peace but I'm saying
where did you get this from because the
majority of terrorist attacks wait tell
me so are you talking about Iraq 1
million people dead Afghanistan half a
million people one second the MOs
shooting the MOs shooting that K MOS
shooting the MOs shooting in Russia that
killed of people by who the government
the government by Manchester AR the L
Bridge T everything by you invaded Iraq
and killed 1 million people about that
I'm know I'm asking you a question now
look there I'm asking you a question
okay show me one place in our religion
that tells us to GQ innocent people
pardon show me one place in the
Quan show show me fighting show me one
place in the Quan that says show me one
show me show me show
me show me one place in the Quran that
says innocent people I I I don't read
the Quran but SE that's why you're
ignorant no no but I've seen enough
about Muslims that killed [__]
innocent people we know what you're in
your in your home
country you think it's okay to
[__] listen to me my seen where in Islam
look to me you said something where in
the Quran does it tell me to go kill
innocent people
I haven't I haven't read the
Quran but I've I've said enough about it
don't you think that's ignorance that
you are making a judgment on something
that you haven't read no I've seen about
it I've seen enough about it I'm ask you
a question if you had the means would
you try to kill me pardon if you had the
means would you try to kill me why I
don't want to kill you why would you
because you have hatred in your eyes if
you had the means I believe you would
kill me okay what about you what would
stop you okay okay what do you want okay
as a Muslim no I would not because my
ReliOn te your Quran says what if Quran
say no in my Quran it says so that's why
you a scumback you show it
oh friend seen
about you seem like you're radicalized
I'm worried for you know why you seem
the type that will attack woman in
hijab you see that no you're no you're
making man you're Mak you're making [__]
up now no no okay why are you so hostile
towards us no because what why you so
hostile towards us why you
hos how how old
he 16 you're 16 listen you're young
you've been radicalized no I haven't me
tell I know I know what's in my brain
and I know what I'm thinking I don't
need you to tell me okay all right do
you not believe that your attitude that
thinking that we are here to take over
and kill no but I know you are are you
why are you here so why I I am here to
live in peace and number two spread my
religion but what about your religion if
peaceful you wouldn't my friend do you
have my friend do you have a do you have
a brain or is he speak
he can iar you no I tell you what I
know why are you here then today if
you're not trying to take over you're
here to try preach your religion try put
it on everyone else but you don't see
that in your head do you do you believe
in freedom of speech pardon do you
believe in freed that's not freedom of
speech do you believe in freedom of
speech no freedom of speech is different
talk you reply I'm talking to do you do
you freedom in speech Define Freedom you
in speech look it's very simple the
freedom to express yourself okay so we
you are expressing yourself are you
expressing yourself okay can I express
myself by about my religion no not
religion that's that's not that's not am
I talking to you or him it's it's it's a
Christian country okay are you a
Christian it's a Christian country it's
notlim
country
hisory
Christian my friend my friend my friend
you you are 16 be here what does it shut
up
man up unusual shut up man shut your
mouth man I'm talking shut your mou shut
your mouth man you're
an you're a clown shut your
being I'm trying to talk to you he's
keep talking over you I'm talking to you
you're being you're being you're on the
verge of being radicalized you're on the
verge of being radicalized look you're
drunk when you're drunk truths come up I
think he's describing himself he's
describing himself why do you have Hate
in Your Heart I don't have hate in my
heart I got love in my heart people
deserve love exactly okay what do you
want to do with Muslims I'm a Muslim
what do you want to do what should Happ
to us ask him if his country is peaceful
Islamic country is
actually the most terrorized
organizations are from Islamic Islamic
groups which
Isis has got enough to do with
Islam
calll to the top most organized friend
organized
terrored my friend my friend my friend
I'm even talking to him I'm his Advocate
can I talk to you him both us no no no
because I'm asking you a question where
in the Quran I ask you question where in
the Quran does it tell me to kill
innocent non-muslims okay where does in
Quran says I'm going to wait for you to
reply I'm going to wait for you to he
hasn't read the
Quran talking about it but i' I've seen
enough about Islam that tells me the
truth that your rle I've seen so much
about all the illegals that coming over
country they come from war zone the
middleaged men goes to Peaceful Islamic
country exactly because they Reon
exactly I agal that's what he's hiding
his face my friend my friend my friend
my friend you're talking about illegal
immigrants this guy's an illegal
immigrant here on the left illegal imant
so this guy is's an illegal immigrant
himself yeah I actually
a so so he's illegal immigrant look he's
an illegal immigrant here you need to
send him back to his country first here
the tax you are from Turkey you said you
you're kurish my friend my friend look
read the Quran look look forget about
what you've seen I'm a Muslim I'm not
here to kill anybody I'm here to talk
about my religion I'm here to have a
discussion and Di we don't need to we
don't need we don't want to that it's a
Christian country we don't want to hear
your religion so you're basically
telling me look Tom Tomy Tomy Robinson
believes in freedom of speech yeah okay
you I'm a Tommy Robinson okay he says
freedom of speech apparently yeah
so country okay can I not Christian
country are you Muslim country why are
you afraid of me talking about the Quran
why are you so scared of that because
it's a Christian country what reason has
your Quran and Muslim do with this
country only 45
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah listen
listen of ignorance get of
ignorance read read the Quran read the
Quran I don't want to read the Quran why
are you afraid name one is why are you
afraid why are you
afraid
afid why afraid there's many there's
many one of them look my friend on
before
look you're a
Youngy 16 years old
Arabic years old 16y old you're going to
get radicalized the Arabic is going to
radicalize you my friend you're a young
you're a young guy you're a young guy
don't let them waste you you're a young
man you have potential
don't listen don't let
don't let you hatred don't let you
hatred don't let you
hatred irrelevant you do nothing I'm
going to join the Army actually why why
do you want to join the Army because to
go and kill more Muslims to go kill more
Muslims no why why you making an
assumption but look look irq you're
making an assumption now you're thinking
all in youred 1 million Iraqi Muslim
Milli to
pales the Palestinians are destroying
the idea why don't you go there
go go to Pal my friend read the Quran I
don't want to read the you have read it
yes have you read yourself have you
you're being shut up I know that guy
Iranian guy told you you would cut your
ear off you remember that guy face man
do you know who my face man you want me
tell you who is move out my face my face
my face my face my face move your camera
my face move out my face move out my
face I will take your mask off I will
take your mask off
I will take your mask I will trust me I
take yourk I will take your
Mas be careful I will you very badly you
hit me you H me I will you very bad
cont being aggressive come try it come
try come try come try you're going to
hit me yeah come try it you're going hit
me try you're being aggressive for what
reason come try it come try it for what
reason what
reive being aggressive you're going to
hit me yeah no you're being
aggressive the police you're being
aggressive mate come tryy being
aggressive
releas call the police now you
police anyways guys this is the enemies
of Islam as you can see listen listen is
in my personal speed with his camera
yeah and she's threatening I'm going to
hit you little
flipping come backo I'll take his mask
off bro I'll make the whole world see
I'll take your mask off I will take your
I will let the whole world see your face
I will take your mask off I'm telling
you yeah I will take your mask off you
little
boy okay anyway no problem it's fine
it's fine listen guys the enemies of
Islam they cannot take us giving da this
is what we're talking about in the da
scene guys they cannot help us spreading
The Message of Islam as you can see what
are we on I will listen get move move
move from our D table move from our D
table move from our D table this table
move from
because he threaten he said I'm going to
hit you he said to me I'm going to hit
you
yeah he's there he said I will hit you
anyways listen my friend listen to me
you're young what's your name Lenny
Lenny my name is Ali yeah okay look I'm
not your enemy I'm not here to take over
I'm here to do nothing I'm just telling
you you're a young guy you're being
you're going to be radicalized they're
trying to make us fight each other while
they're doing some listen I'm you're not
my enemy I I I'll BL I'll blame listen
listen I have no problem with you you're
a young 16-year-old boy you've got so
much potential ahead of you okay I'm
just telling you me and you are not
going to be here bickering fighting
while the big guys in the back Zionist
are making all kind of Madness happen
okay do you see do you see look there
you go what I'm telling look I will take
your mask off I promise you I'll will
take your mask off yeah the whole world
will see okay so so I'm telling you
guats
again taking a mask off there you
go you're you're still threatening them
yes no no no I'm not threaten him you
are though you're saying I'm you're
threatening to take his mask off how's
that not a threat because he's a threat
to me if I came to you with a B of Club
you see me as a you say I want to see
your face but anyway guys I'm going to
say by read the Quan man you're not my
enemy you're a young man you
[Music]
got we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of of Allah subhana
wa tala in the country of Norway click
on the link and donate now for the sake
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala